I fish on she goes up in here start
weird let's get weird with this oh my
god Rockstar Cheetos it kind of it looks
like a Cheeto week for nice flavorful is
real to you mom you might know it's more
tasty Aaron
these are British balls easy spicy balls
cheesy spicy balls take a ball wide oh
whoa these kind of taste like the chili
cheese Fritos a little bit these tastes
like someone was smoking a cigarette
took a bag of the easy way the beginning
of it was surprising the middle of it
was weird and the aftertaste with
sawdust the aftertaste kind of comes in
there and aftertaste sucks
whoa baby like vampire Cheetos oh but I
guess work should you go like cinnamon
dude
sauce pack it up in here is this salsa
oh it's disgusting
yeah you're not gonna like I'm putting
that back in this packaging is that a
kebab yeah dude that's kebab flavor it
smells like burnt rubber beef steaks
some grilled onions and grilled peppers
yeah man that's good Oh
dog food could use more beef it isn't
just like a barbecue it's like you were
eating something there's a barbecue
going on next door Patsy yeah schewe
schewe
are these even Cheetos oh it smells like
Pepsi
Oh No Wow
well what I like this the flavors they
nailed later in Pepsi you know what it
tastes like you know when you drink
Pepsi and then you just burp this made a
deal with the devil there's no way that
cheeto should bubble in your mouth I
hate all of them basically um the only
way to do Cheetos is American why do you
like all the worst ones no I don't
understand no what is wrong with you you
like them no this is good don't let it
touch different parts of your tongue it
gets bad no matter what party time can
guarantee this is a kid